[Music]
it's likely not a surprise to anyone
that to live rich you gotta spend rich
and that has only become pricier over
the past year we at forbes have been
keeping tabs on the cost of the good
life since 1982 tracking a basket of
ultra luxury items to compute what's
known as our cost of living extremely
well index this year that index is up
10.1 percent the biggest jump since
2008. that's nearly twice as much as the
u.s consumer price index which rose 5.3
percent over the same period it's the
usual suspects pushing up prices
increased demand the rising cost of raw
materials and manufactured goods and
labor shortages from the pandemic in
case you're curious here's some of the
bigger price increases for a number of
goods and services frequented by the
ultra wealthy an oyster 595 sailing
yacht is now 3 million four hundred
thousand dollars for an increase of
thirty point eight percent an audemars
piguet royal oak is now twenty three
thousand nine hundred dollars an
increase of thirty four point three
percent
an olympic-sized pool is three million
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
or an increase of fifty two point nine
percent
a facelift from an experienced plastic
surgeon in new york now costs thirty two
thousand five hundred dollars for an
increase of 51.2 percent
45 minutes with an upper east side
psychiatrist in new york now costs 450
dollars that's an increase of 12.5
percent and a 40 person catered dinner
from ridgewell's maryland now cost
for an increase of
16.7 percent
yet with all of these increases if
you're on the forbes 400 you probably
don't have much to worry about that's
because the 11.1 billion dollar average
net worth of list members has also gone
up 39 this year which is more than
triple the increase in prices
[Music]
you